QUITE CLEAR WHICH SIDE IS
WINNING, BECAUSE, OF COURSE,
THIS MOBILIZATION IS ALSO A
GREAT INTIMIDATION TOOL.
NOBODY IS SAFE.
AT THE SAME TIME, LOTS OF PEOPLE
ARE REALLY, REALLY ANGRY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ANDREI.
I APPRECIATE IT.
COLONEL, PLEASE STAY WITH ME,
BECAUSE MY NEXT STORY HERE IS
SOMETHING I KNOW YOU KNOW A LOT
ABOUT.
WE ARE MONITORING A LIVE
SITUATION RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ACTUALLY A MAJOR COLLISION
IN SPACE.
SO LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT IT.
THIS IS A LIVE IMAGE ON YOUR
SCREEN.
NASA IS ABOUT TO INTENTIONALLY
CRASH A SPACECRAFT INTO AN
ASTEROID.
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
WE'RE LITERALLY IN THE LAST
MINUTE.
THE ASTEROID NAMED DIMORPHOS.
CALL IT DART.
DIMORPHOS POSES NO THREAT TO
EARTH, BUT THEY'RE SEEING IF
THEY CAN PUSH IT OFF COURSE.
IT IS THE FIRST TIME NASA IS
ATTEMPTING A TEST LIKE THIS.
LET'S GO STRAIGHT TO KRISTIN
FISHER AT JOHNS HOPKINS APPLIED
PHYSICS LAB.
SHE IS IN MARYLAND.
COLONEL LEIGHTON IS HERE.
KRISTIN, WE'VE GOT THIS LIVE
IMAGE ON THE SCREEN.
YOU'RE THERE IN THE CONTROL
ROOM.
THIS IS A FIRST, AN
UNPRECEDENTED EVENT.
TELL US WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
>> ERIN, WE ARE NOW EXACTLY 2:58
TO IMPACT.
AND WHAT YOU'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW
ON YOUR SCREEN IS ALL LIVE
IMAGES FROM A CAMERA THAT IS
MOUNTED ON THE DART SPACECRAFT.
AND FOR A MISSION THIS
COMPLICATED AND CONSEQUENTIAL,
WHAT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN IS
ACTUALLY QUITE SIMPLE.
NASA IS GOING TO TAKE THIS
MULTIMILLION-DOLLAR SPACECRAFT
AND JUST SLAM IT INTO AN
ASTEROID.
NOT THE ASTEROID, THE BIGGEST
ONE RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU ON
YOUR SCREEN THAT BIG ASTEROID AT
THE CENTER OF YOUR SCREEN JUST
TO THE LEFT, THAT IS DIDYMOS
THAT IS WHAT THE DART SPACECRAFT
HAS BEEN TARGETING FOR THE
BETTER PART OF TEN MONTHS WHILE
IT'S BEEN IN SPACE.
ITS TARGET IS THAT SMALLER
ASTEROID, DIMORPHOS.
AND SO THIS SPACECRAFT IS
TRAVELING AT A SPEED OF 4 MILES
PER SECOND, NOT PER HOUR, FOUR
MILES PER SECOND.
THAT'S ABOUT 14,000 MILES PER
HOUR.
AND ERIN, IT IS GOING TO IN TWO
MINUTES SLAM INTO THAT SMALLER
ASTEROID ON THE RIGHT,
DIMORPHOS.
YOU'RE GOING TOE WATCH AS IT
FILLS YOUR SCREEN.
AND THEN WHEN IT HIT, IT'S JUST
GOING TO GO BLACK.
COMPLETE LOSS OF SIGNAL.
ONE OF THE ONLY TIMES THAT
YOU'RE GOING SEE A NASA MISSION
CONTROL ROOM HOPEFULLY CHEER AT
THE DESTRUCTION OF A SPACECRAFT
AND THE LOSS OF SIGNAL, ERIN.
>> RIGHT.
TO HAVE SOMETHING GO TO BLACK,
THE LAST THING YOU WOULD WANT ON
ANY ORDINARY MISSION.
BUT THIS IS NO ORDINARY MISSION,
COLONEL.
>> RIGHT.
>> KRISTIN EXPLAINING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SMALLER DOT
THAT IS DIMORPHOS.
DIMORPHOS IS THE ONE IT'S GOING
TO SLAM INTO.
IT'S ABOUT THE SIZE I UNDERSTAND
OF EGYPT'S GREAT PYRAMID.
THE SPACECRAFT IS EQUIVALENT TO
THE SIZE OF A REFRIGERATOR.
AND YOU'RE IN THE VAST VACUUM OF
SPACE HERE.
HOW AMAZING IS IT THAT NASA
COULD PULL THIS OFF?
>> THIS IS INCREDIBLY AMAZING.
THIS IS REALLY THE FIRST TIME,
ERIN, THAT WE ARE USING THINGS
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IN
SCIENCE FICTION, YOU KNOW,
THINGS THAT WE SEE IN MOVIES,
AND IN TV SERIES THAT IS REALLY
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE PLANET
ITSELF.
YOU KNOW, YOU GO BACK TO THE
TIME OF THE DINOSAURS, AND
YOU -- THE THEORY IS THAT
DINOSAURS WERE MADE EXTINCT
BECAUSE OF AN ASTEROID OR A
SERIES OF ASTEROIDS HITTING THE
EARTH.
THERE WAS A CASE IN RUSSIA IN
THE EARLY LATE 19th CENTURY,
EARLY 20th CENTURY WHERE WE
ACTUALLY HAD AN ASTEROID HIT
SIBERIA THAT RESULTED IN A LOT
OF DESTRUCTION OF TERRITORY
THERE.
LUCKILY NOT VERY POPULATED
TERRITORY, BUT STILL, THE DANGER
IS DEFINITELY THERE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT EVEN
THOUGH THE PROBABILITY IS LOW,
IT'S ONE OF THOSE LOW
PROBABILITY-HIGH IMPACT THINGS
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
SO WITH THIS EXPERIMENT, WE'RE
LOOKING AT NASA POTENTIALLY
BEING ABLE TO PROTECT OUR PLANET
FROM ASTEROIDS OF THE FUTURE.
>> AND WE'RE WATCHING HERE AS
THE SPACECRAFT D.A.R.T.
APPROACHES DIMORPHOS.
YOU CAN SEE IT GETTING CLOSER
AND CLOSER.
WE'RE HERE IN THE FINAL FEW
SECONDS.
14,000 MILES AN HOUR IS WHAT
YOU'RE WATCHING.
THE CAMERA THAT WE'RE WATCHING
IS TRAVELING 14,000 MILES AN
HOUR ON D.A.R.T., THE
SPACECRAFT, THE
REFRIGERATOR-SIZED SPACECRAFT
THAT'S GOING SLAM INTO DIMORPHOS
HERE.
WE'RE LITERALLY A FEW SECONDS
AWAY.
SO I UNDERSTAND, KRISTIN, AS IT
GETS CLOSER, WE'RE GOING SEE IT
GET CLOSER AND CLOSER.
I HEAR A LOT OF TALKING BEHIND
YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE AN EXPLOSION
AND GO TO BLACK?
>> AMAZING, GUYS!
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ERIN.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ANY SECOND
NOW AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE BIG
CHEERS GO UP IN THE MISSION
CONTROL WHICH IS RIGHT HERE.
YOU JUST GOT SOME OTHER FOLKS
HERE CHEERING.
BUT THIS IS IT, THE MOMENT,
D.A.R.T. HIT ING THE DAY MORE
FOES ASTEROID.
RIGHT NOW, WOW, LOOK AT THE
DETAIL THAT YOU CAN SEE.
>> IT IS AMAZING.
IT LOOKS LIKE A --
>> THOSE ARE ROCKS ON THE
SURFACE OF DIMORPHOS OF SOME
KIND.
BIG CHEERS GOING UP HERE INSIDE
THE JOHNS HOPKINS APPLIED
PHYSICS LABORATORY.
ERIN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH
TIME AND ENERGY THE PEOPLE IN
THIS ROOM HAVE -- HOW MUCH TIME
AND EFFORT THEY'VE PUT INTO THIS
BEING A SUCCESS.
AND THERE, I THINK YOU CAN SEE
THE CROWD CHEERING DOWN IN
MISSION CONTROL.
PROBABLY THE ONLY TIME THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CHEER FOR A LOSS
OF A SPACECRAFT, ERIN.
>> AND WE HAVE IMPACT!
>> IN THE NAME OF PLANETARY
DEFENSE.
PRETTY AMAZING TO SEE IT.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE THE --
OBVIOUSLY CELEBRATION IN THAT
ROOM.
TALK ABOUT THREADING A NEEDLE,
KRISTIN.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THEY JUST
SENT FROM EARTH AN OBJECT THE
SIZE OF A REFRIGERATOR INTO AN
OBJECT THE SIZE OF THE GREAT
PYRAMID IN THE MIDDLE OF SPACE
AT 14,000 MILES AN HOUR.
AND THEY HIT IT.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
SO NOW, ERIN, THE NEXT BIG
CHALLENGE, NASA HAS COMPLETED
ITS FIRST BIG OBJECTIVE.
THEY'VE PROVEN THAT THEY CAN DO
THIS.
THEY'VE PROVEN THAT THEY CAN
TAKE THIS SPACECRAFT AND SLAM IT
INTO AN ASTEROID.
NOW THE BIG QUESTION IS WERE
THEY ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY MOVE
THIS ASTEROID OFF ITS CURRENT
ORBIT?
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO MOVE IT BY
A LOT.
THIS ASTEROID IS NOT GOING TO
BLOW INTO A MILLION PIECES LIKE
YOU SAW IN "ARMAGEDDON."
ALL THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IS MOVE
IT SLIGHTLY OFF ITS ORBIT SO IF
THIS WERE TO HAPPEN IN THE
FUTURE WHERE THERE WERE AN
ASTEROID THAT WAS POTENTIALLY
GOING TO WIPE OUT ALL OF LIFE AS
WE KNOW IT ON PLANET EARTH,
COULD THEY DO THIS FAR ENOUGH IN
ADVANCE AND KNOCK THIS KILLER
ASTEROID OFF ORBIT AND SAVE THE
PLANET.
THAT'S TRULY THE TECHNOLOGY THAT
THEY ARE TESTING HERE.
SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE A FEW
WEEKS BEFORE WE KNOW IF THEY'VE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THAT
OBJECTIVE.
THEY DO IT BY USING GROUND-BASED
TELESCOPES THAT CAN ACTUALLY SEE
THE ORBIT OF THAT ASTEROID, SEE
IF THEY WERE ABLE TO PUSH IT OFF
COURSE.
BUT TONIGHT, I MEAN, YOU SEE
THESE CELEBRATIONS GOING ON IN
MISSION CONTROL.
JUST A BIG MOMENT FOR THIS TEAM
PROVING THAT NASA'S FIRST
PLANETARY DEFENSE TEST MISSION
IS AT LEAST 50% OF BIG SUCCESS
HERE.
>> AND CERTAINLY, TO BE CHEER
HERE, IF YOU HAD AN ASTEROID
ABOUT FIVE TIMES BIGGER THAN
THIS ONE, IT COULD DESTROY
CIVILIZATION AS WE KNOW IT,
RIGHT?
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS, IF THIS
WORKS, RIGHT, IN TERMS OF
PRESERVING CIVILIZATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY, ERIN.
THE KEY THING HERE TO REMEMBER
IS THAT THESE TYPES OF ASTEROIDS
CAN COME IN VARIOUS SIZES.
THEY CAN POSE VERY TYPES OF
THREATS TO THE PLANET.
AND BY DOING THIS TEST, WHAT
NASA HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO IS
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO SHOW, AS
WE'VE SEEN JUST TONIGHT, THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THAT T